Let’s look at this situation which we’d
seen in one of our earlier videos.
Two beakers are connected by a pipe and one
of the beakers is placed at a
height above the other, and the water will
flow from this beaker to this one.
Now listen to me carefully.
If you understand this simple situation well,
you
will understand Ohm’s Law too!
Just focus for the next two minutes, and you
will master Ohm’s law!
As we’d discussed, it is the height difference
that makes the water flow from
the beaker on top to the one at the bottom.
What happens if I increase the
height difference?
The flow of water will be faster correct?
Absolutely!
So we
can say that the FLOW of water is directly
proportional to the height
difference…
F α H
Now let’s look at another factor: How THIN
the pipe is!
What will happen if I
make the pipe thinner?
The flow of water will be slower right?
That’s correct!
Thinner the pipe, slower the flow!
So we can say that the flow is INVERSELY
proportional to thinness.
F α
Looking at these two relations, we can say
that the flow is equal to H over t.
F = (ignoring the constants)
The flow is directly proportional to the height
difference, and inversely
proportional to the thinness.
Why did I give you this example?
Because it’s ANALOGOUS to the Ohm’s Law.
The flow of water is analogous to the flow
of CURRENT.
The height difference
is analogous to the voltage or POTENTIAL DIFFERENCE!
And the thinness is
analogous to the RESISTANCE.
I =
The flow of current is directly proportional
to the potential difference between
the points and inversely proportional to the
resistance.
If the potential difference between two points
is more, the current flowing
through it will be more!
And if the resistance is more, the current
flowing
through will be lesser!
This is assuming that the other factors are
constant.
This is the basic concept of Ohm’s Law and
there are many different ways in
which we can understand it.
We will dive a bit deeper into this concept
in the
coming videos!